3000 silex taillés datés entre moins
2500 et moins 6000 avant jésus-christ
une vente exceptionnelle dans la région
et qui a surtout réveiller les enchères
à l'international sur internet et par
téléphone dans la salle des curieux
évidemment ébahi par autant de pièces
d'histoire lu ça sur internet est bon il
y avait de bien belles pièces et on est
venu à toulouse c'est pas sûr qu on
achète quoi que ce soit ils viennent
bien les pierres à après voilà avant moi
regardez qu'est ce que c'est
non on était première fois que je viens
ici voilà on va connaître
comment faire comment ça fonctionne
c'est sa conjointe pour hacher avec mon
fils
et on va acheter mais bon j'ai pas quoi
on a coché plusieurs choses
pour le commissaire priseur locale la
séance est inédite tous les lots
appartenait à une famille tourangelle
ils constituaient deux collections
débuter à la fin du 19e et au début du
xxème toutes ces pierres façonné ont été
découvertes en indre et loire dans les
vallées de la cnes et de la creuse une
vente vraiment inhabituel totalement
inhabituel est probablement la seule de
ma carrière je pense pas avoir
l'occasion de revendre autant d'outils
provenant du même site et puis avec
cette quantité et puis des hommes
quelques objets tram 3200 euros pour une
lame de couteau un prix étonnants les
vestiges de la préhistoire continue à
fasciner la touraine et plus
particulièrement le sud du département
de l'indre et loire reste l'un des
gisements les plus importants de silex
du néolithique un savoir faire qui à
l'époque si disséminés partout en europe
et qui aujourd'hui fait le bonheur de
bon nombre de collectionneurs